Speaker 1: In response to the home invasion
attack on Nancy Pelosi's husband, Paul Pelosi,
Elon Musk, fresh off of buying Twitter, tweeted
a bonkers conspiracy theory from the Santa
monica Observer, a paper publication which
previously reported that Hillary Clinton died
before the 2016 election and a body double
was debating Donald Trump.
Elon Musk tweeted such a conspiracy theory
that claims or suggests that the home invader
was actually Paul Pelosi's gay lover.
Completely baseless and ultimately deleted
that.
This is the owner of Twitter that did this
article about this on CBS News.
Elon Musk Tweets and deletes link to article
Pushing Unfounded Conspiracy Theory About
Paul Pelosi attack and it reads Elon Musk
Sunday tweeted and deleted a link to an article
pushing an unfounded conspiracy theory about
the attack on Paul Pelosi.
The tweet from Musk, who now owns Twitter,
raised concerns about the type of content
that will be allowed on social media on the
social media site under his control.
Yeah, that's an understatement.
In a since deleted tweet responding to Hillary
Clinton, Musk wrote, There is a tiny possibility
there might be more to this story than meets
the eye with a link to a story from the right
wing website.
Santa monica Observer a site that has pushed
anti LGBT conspiracy theory regarding the
attack.
According to an archived version of the story,
the outlet previously made false claims, including
that Hillary Clinton died on 911 and was replaced
by a lookalike.
You can still find an archive of the story
that was posted and the story says it doesn't
add up.
People on social media are questioning the
attack on Paul Pelosi and it says, you know,
San Francisco's gay bars close at 2 a.m.
And what happened was the bar's closed.
Paul Pelosi went home with his lover and it
was a lover's quarrel.
A lover's quarrel.
Now, Ben Collins on MSNBC explains how this
entire thing got going.
And it really is instructive in terms of how
this nonsense starts with a spark and very
quickly becomes a fire that is difficult to
put out.
Speaker 4: First of all, lies on the air faster
than the truth.
And that's in part why there are all these
safeguards that Elon Musk is trying to take
down on Twitter right now.
The lies that were pushed were from that piece
of information they found.
For example, they said that Paul Pelosi was
in his underwear.
Of course, it was 230 in the morning at the
time he was attacked.
That led them to believe this was a lover's
quarrel between two different people that
knew each other.
The reason they believe they knew each other
is because the police put out a statement
saying that they didn't really know who opened
the door.
So that led them to believe there was a third
person in the house.
So from there, there was this world building
on the pro-Trump Internet.
What could be the opposite of reality here?
And the opposite reality they came up with
was these two people were having a lover's
quarrel in a house and the police sort of
intruded on us.
It's fundamentally incorrect.
It was pushed by the richest man in the world.
And then yesterday it was pushed by Donald
Trump Jr, who posted a picture of underwear
and a hammer and served as a Halloween costume
for Pelosi.
If we don't cut this out right now, not just
the normalization of violence, but the idea
that reality can't even exist anymore because
it cannot catch up to lies on the Internet.
I'm not a scholar on authoritarian history,
but I've I've read Hannah Arendt.
I've read all of these people.
This is how it gets really bad.
This is the start of something that gets really,
really bad.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
And Ben Collins is, of course, completely
correct.
And the added layer to it now is forget about
whether Elon Musk is going to properly moderate
at Twitter, the dissemination of outrageous
disinformation.
He's participating in spreading it, which
is a new dystopian layer altogether.
Let me know what you think.
Find me on Twitter.
And remember, if you are watching our content
on YouTube and you are not subscribed.
What on earth are you thinking?
No.
In all seriousness, our YouTube channel is
on its way to 2 million subscribers.
We found out that there are millions of YouTube
viewers who watch our content every month
and don't subscribe.
Make sure to hit that subscribe button.
It does so much for us.
It is the most important indicator to YouTube.
Hey, should we recommend David Pac-Man's content
or not?
So speaking specifically to those of you who
watch the clips, but that subscribe button
is enabled because you're not currently subscribed.
Do us a favor and hit that button will be
at 2 million subscribers before you know it.
We will take a quick break and be back right
after this.
Remember that The David Pakman Show is a viewer
and listener supported program.
We do an extra show every single day for our
members called The Bonus Show.
Speaker 5: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund.
Speaker 6: Themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Consider yourselves invited to
sign up at join Packman dot com.
Would love to have you.
You can use the coupon code.
Big voting 22 through election day.
Then that coupon code goes away.
Big voting 22 to get yourself a discount.